you know what I [__] hate about all
those movies that I enjoyed in the ' 80s
and then people go it was Laten
homosexuality it's like yeah if you were
gay I just thought it was a bunch of
guys [__] playing volleyball I never
thought that they were blowing each
other after it that's on you right yes
dude if I had that body I'm no shirt on
the beach playing volleyball hot out it
was an impromptu game of volleyball you
saw they had their jeans on yeah they're
not going to all start sucking each
other's dick when the game's over like
Batman Robin oh there a really
homosexual thing going on there was
there I thought Batman was trying to
[__] Catwoman it's like yeah are you
sure maybe this might be a u
issue yeah I think you're gay I think
you want to see these guys start
queering off with each other which is
fine but don't [__] tell me that that
was the purpose of that scene that scene
was supposed to get women all excited to
go to the movie that's why they had them
oiled up they didn't do it for me